during yesterday's show I made a
prediction that in retrospect was a bit
premature I said that Apple's Mother
Nature skit would be by far the
cringiest example of corporate virtue
signaling over the past few weeks in
case you missed it Tim Cook trotted out
an overweight black woman playing Gaia
who was written to be as obnoxious and
overbearing as possible and this
plus-sized Mother Nature kept harassing
a bunch of chubby Multicultural actors
playing Apple Executives about their
environmental initiatives and of course
the Apple Executives being the committed
pagans that they are somehow managed to
meet all of her demands and after
watching that in my defense it didn't
seem like any other major corporation
could one-up Apple in terms of
over-the-top Shameless pandering to the
most unappealing self-loathing elements
of the far left but as it turns out
Apple was not the only big company
recently that has been looking to
exploit the archetype of a severely
overweight black woman for political
game Dove which is supposedly a beauty
company has just doubled down on that
strategy they've hired a morbidly obese
BLM grifter by the name of Ziana Bryant
and this effort by them in terms of
wokeness it really Takes the Cake in
every conceivable sense of the phrase
Dove's latest marketing strategy is not
simply cringy it's not simply calibrated
to deliver a very clear anti-white
message it's also a window into the
logical endpoint of leftism because it's
a manifestation
of all of these seven deadly sins really
but especially gluttony and sloth now
before I get into why this is such a
revealing moment
we should begin with the first Instagram
video that Dove has um paid this Ziana
Bryant person to make and this is
apparently what companies do now when
they want to light their reputations on
fire but light did it and now Dove is
getting in on the action watch my belief
is that we should be centering the
voices and experiences of the most
marginalized people and communities at
all times so when I think about what fat
Liberation looks like to me it looks
like centering the voices and the
experiences of those who live in and who
maneuver through spaces and institutions
in a fat body it looks like making
accessible spaces and having
conversations that are aware of the fact
that people have different bodies and
that they are interacting with space and
people and institutions and communities
in a different way beautiful woman uh
obviously goes without saying now and
notice also she says we have to Center
the voices of supposedly marginalized
people at all times at all times so she
should be the center always there's
never a time when anyone else should be
a designer it's always her now this is
not the critical point here but it's
always also worth noting the Absurd
comically pretentious way that these
people speak
the woke crowd speaks in something that
is not really a human language I mean
nobody talks this way maneuvering
through spaces and a fat body no normal
human being would ever use a phrase like
that okay that what have you ever heard
someone say that in conversation well
you know I'm just maneuvering through
this space and a body
you're not maneuvering through a space
in a fat body you're just a fat girl
walking into a room that's what you're
doing
but their worldview is so empty it's so
vacuous it's so lacking in any
intellectual substance that they have to
add 14 extra syllables to every sentence
to distract people from the fundamental
stupidity of everything that they're
saying
anyway Zion O'Brien is a member of a
marginalized group she says and she's
seeking something called fat Liberation
now you might assume that the way to
achieve fat Liberation is to go for a
jog and eat a salad but that's not what
she means and to her it means that we
need to be aware of the fact that people
have different bodies apparently that
was something that most Americans were
not aware of we needed Zion O'Brien to
tell us people have different bodies and
then we and then we all said oh people
have I thought everyone had the same
body I didn't realize fat people existed
because we somehow didn't notice you
when you walked into the room
now to understand what the actual
purpose of this advertising campaign is
you need to know more about Ziana Bryant
and why she's a hero in leftist circles
so uh that goes back to the summer of
2020.
during the BLM riots
when Bryant who again is supposedly a
member of a marginalized group destroyed
the life of a white student at the
University of Virginia named Morgan
bettinger the details of what happened
are outlined in bettinger's recent
lawsuit against UVA UVA alleging
anti-white discrimination by the
school's administrators who endorsed
Brian's lies
this is a lawsuit that hasn't gotten
much coverage But ultimately it could
rival The Landmark litigation against
Oberlin by Gibson's Bakery which Oberlin
smeared as racist we talked about that
in the past that lawsuit as you might
remember remember ended with a 36
million dollar verdict against Oberlin
and UVA May soon face something similar
so here's the background
on the evening of July 17 2020 bettinger
was driving through downtown
Charlottesville in her Subaru station
wagon and that's when she came across a
massive BLM protest that as BLM protests
tend to do was blocking all of the major
roads in town demonstrators were lying
on the roadway obstructing traffic
and to protect these protesters from
getting hit by cars the city of
Charlottesville deployed a dump truck to
block the main road completely so the
city did not arrest the BLM rioters for
breaking the law and preventing people
from going where they needed to go
instead the city effectively encouraged
them and even participated in the riot
by blocking the roads to give them space
to Riot which goes back to the
infamously several years ago the mayor
of Baltimore said that if if people want
to Riot we need to give them space to
destroy and that of course is what many
cities did during 2020 Charlottesville
no exception so they lent the thugs a
dump truck uh for the purpose of of
being able to have the riot
now bettinger understandably didn't know
what to do she was trying to get home
from her 12-hour shift at her summer job
and she didn't know like how am I
supposed to get home he blocked all the
roads after waiting a bit she exited her
car approached the dump truck driver to
see what was going on and she said she
said the following words to dump truck
driver or something to this effect okay
she said quote well it's a good thing
you're here because otherwise they could
be speed bumps referring to the
protesters lying in the street
like saying that well it's good you're
here because otherwise they're good
people to run over them and they turn
into speed
this was such an innocuous conversation
that when University investigators later
asked the dump truck driver about it he
had no recollection that bettinger had
had said anything to him because it was
it was nothing it was it was a nothing
conversation and there was nothing
threatening in her tone
she was making an idol observation to
one person about the fact that the dump
truck driver was preventing those
rioters from getting run over by cars
but some of the BLM Riders nearby heard
benjer's comment and they decided that
it was somehow a threat and they swarmed
her car and threatened to kill her
one of the BLM activists who didn't hear
what benjer said but was nonetheless
very offended by it was Zion O'Brien
Bryant wrote a series of viral tweets
claiming that bettinger's statement
which she heard about second hand
amounted to a dangerous Act of white
supremacy for example she wrote quote
email these UVA Deans now to demand that
Morgan faced consequences for her
actions and at UVA stopped graduating
races
remember the the the BLM writers swarmed
her car attacking her
but she's the one who needs to face
consequences
in response to this local news outlets
accepted Brian's claims without any
hesitation
one Outlet Seaville reported that
bettinger had issued a chilling and
violent threat
several UVA faculty members openly
mocked bettinger as well as bettinger's
faith and called for her immediate
expulsion
the school opened not one but three
investigations into bettinger and
ultimately UVA kicked her out of school
banned her from stepping foot on campus
they released public statements implying
that she's a white supremacist
very quickly under the guidance of a UVA
Dean a four-member panel of
undergraduates convicted bettinger of
misconduct during a one of these
kangaroo trials at three in the morning
this was not exactly a rigorous judicial
process evidence showed shows that that
if the panel of undergraduates didn't
convict her they feared that the day's
big football game would have been
canceled by a BLM Riot so under the
threat of riots they convicted her of uh
they they gave the writers exactly what
they wanted
now around the same time
um
as the lawsuit lays out UVA took other
actions that made it clear that they
have a strong and pervasive anti-white
bias on campus to give one example a
black student stood up and told white
students to leave the common area on
campus and because they're white and the
administration didn't do anything about
and that incident was caught on video
several more examples just like that one
in the suit it wasn't until more than a
year after the incident that UVA cleared
bettinger of wrongdoing although they
still treated her like a pariah and Zion
O'Brien had long last over a year later
admitted that she might have misheard
what she was told secondhand uh and uh
and and so maybe she was wrong about it
but by that point the damage was done
bettinger's career prospects were ruined
she wanted to go to law school but no
law school would take her her employer
fired her
you know she was smeared publicly
Nationwide as a white supremacist
after all the death threats and
investigations and and the public smear
campaign to this day Morgan Badger
suffers from an array of serious
psychological problems I mean real site
this is actual real trauma
That She's suffering from
and and just to emphasize the Injustice
that was done to bettinger
consider that this treatment would have
been way way overboard even if she had
really done what they accused her of
doing
so even if she had said in a threatening
or taunting way that the idiots lying in
the road would become speed bumps or
even if she said they should become
speed bumps even if she got out of her
car and yelled and said you all should
become speed bumps you're lying in the
road you morons
let's say she had said that she didn't
but what if she did
that still would not even come close to
justifying anything that was done to her
in that case she would be expressing
entirely understandable frustration at
the moronic thugs clogging up the roads
and she would be saying and thinking
what really almost everyone says or at
least thinks when there are a bunch of
idiot protesters blocking the road
and she shouldn't face any consequence
at all for that but but that's not what
happened that's not what she said or did
and her life was still destroyed well
it's clear to the left is giving up
their morals and any Common Sense
there's no better time to build a habit
of daily prayer meditation building a
habit of prayer can help you cultivate
an attitude of gratitude focusing on
what you are thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hello is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the U.S it
helped me maintain a daily prayer
routine can help you do the same
download the app for free at hollow.com
Matt Walsh you can set prayer reminders
and track your progress along the way
not sure where to start we'll check out
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year
podcast available on the hollow app or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel even some world-class athletes
with Hollow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using hello to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
as well ultimately we'll learn how we
can become better individuals in spite
of today's broken World As We strive to
become more like Christ in our daily
lives through prayer fasting and giving
download hello.com Matt Walsh you get an
exclusive three months free that's three
months absolutely free at hello.com Matt
Walsh
Diana Bryan's life on the other hand has
had a very different trajectory for
destroying a white student at UVA based
on a falsehood Bryant has received one
award after another in 2021 a year after
her lies went viral Bryant was honored
by Al Sharpton's National Action Network
which is supposedly a Civil Rights group
the National Action Network
name to Brian as somehow the youth
activist of the year
and here's part of her acceptance speech
watch
I am so honored to be receiving this
year's youth activist of the Year award
I know that young people have always led
the way on the front lines of some of
our country's most Progressive issues
and even internationally
young black youth are so
multifaceted so gifted so talented and
able to bring together
crowds of people of many different ages
and many different walks of life
well Zana Brian definitely demonstrated
that she can bring people together bring
crowds of people together as she says
that much is clear with the National
Action Network is doing here is honoring
someone who gathered a Lynch Mob to
harass threaten and to fame a young
woman a young innocent woman
solely because of her skin color two
years later Dove is doing the same thing
now at some level this isn't surprising
Dove has been on this trajectory for a
while they've Unleashed one woke
advertising campaign after another this
month the company set up Billboards in
New York's Times Square showing a bunch
of women exposing their unshaven armpits
and his outkick pointed out recently
Dove is owned by Unilever which owns Ben
and Jerry's maybe the single most
anti-American Corporation you can find
outside of Tehran uh this is a beauty
company that is clearly set on promoting
ugliness and left-wing propaganda
but I repeat myself
but even by the standards of corporate
wokeness this latest move by Dove is
extraordinary I mean it's revolting in
every sense yes and it's a deeply
bizarre Act of self-sabotage by a brand
that's already flailing but it's also a
clear sign that we're approaching
perhaps the end of the runway runaway
train of leftist ideology that's taken
hold of this country in recent years the
fat Liberation movement that they're
embracing is you might say The Logical
endpoint of leftism
it's what we've been leading up to after
the past decade or so fat Liberation and
body acceptance explicitly promote and
glorify Hedonism they enable the most
useless people to feel like Martyrs and
heroes
I mean all you have to do is lie around
and eat and suddenly you're part of a of
a movement
and once you're that inert and Powerless
there's not much else you can do there's
not really any more activism you can
undertake at that point
I expect the fat Liberation movement to
become more and more popular
like this is this is the movement of the
future this is the future of leftism
because it's it's the perfect
opportunity for those who crave victim
points
all you have to do is nothing nothing
but eat and you can gain access to a
marginalized group along with all the
social capital that comes with it
it's no surprise that Corporate America
is a fan of this idea they want us all
to be mindless consumers sitting around
sedentary with our mouths open ingesting
whatever they shovel in
that's why it's not just dove that's
pushing this it's why Apple selected
several overweight actors for their
little mother nature sketch as I
mentioned it's why Calvin Klein and
Abercrombie and Victoria's Secret now
throw obese models in our faces why
Gatorade supposedly a brand that
promotes athleticism is putting fat yoga
instructors in its ads and so on and we
see this all over the place
at the height of the Occupy Wall Street
movement which was the last time
Corporate America was truly worried
about the left in this country there was
a saying that you would hear a lot
outside of the the home of J.P Morgan's
president outside citibank's corporate
headquarters activists with Chan Eat the
Rich
well it took a while but these Mega
corporations have finally found a way to
stop those chants outside their offices
and ensure that they'll never again come
back
the race stuff and the BLM propaganda
the transistoria it's a good start
but now they've identified their
finishing move they realize that what
they need to do is to convince the left
to eat not to eat the rich but just to
eat
and as of now that effort is is
succeeding beyond their wildest
imagination
they are sleeping soundly in the
financial district tonight
that's because they know that the fat
Liberation movement now Unleashed
will soon devour what remains of the
left
if you'd like to see what else I have to
say you can access my full show by going
to dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
Walsh Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed